Yes,
if it was a desert island scenario and I
like to take one font with me,
I guess it would be Helvetica though
though it has its limitations.
I think it's incredibly versatile and,
and gets the job done.
And I also think it's,
I think it's one of the few typefaces
that will really survive the test of
time,
um,
you know,
beyond the next several decades,
if not into the next century.
I think.
I think there's just something that was
just really done right when that type
face was put together and not just that.
I think it,
the,
the conversation that,
that sort of,
um,
of,
uh,
grew around Helvetica,
especially over the past,
uh,
five years ago has really solidified as
a timeless classic.
So that's the one I would take with me.
Um,
it's,
it's certainly not the only one,
but,
but if,
if press,
that would be the one.
Well.
Um,
I think,
um,
you know,
our colleagues over at the Guardian are
doing a really great job,
um,
with their news presentation.
And I think,
um,
the art director over there,
uh,
who's,
Mark Porter,
Mark Porter over at,
at the Guardian,
I think he's doing a terrific job with,
uh,
the news presentation.
He's a guy who came from a print
background.
He was a art director from the newspaper
for a long time.
And what I really like about that
example is he was,
you know,
quite modest in coming to the web and
really understood that it required him
to really immerse himself for a year,
if not,
you know,
several years to really get the medium.
And the results are really,
really,
I think,
quite amazing.
Um,
it's a very,
um,
very nicely controlled evenly,
sort of,
uh,
sort of executed,
news experience over there that,
that at the same time really respects
users' needs and goals and responds to
them.
And so I think,
I think that's terrific.
You know,
at the same time they have a different
economic situation,
then the times does,
which I'm quite jealous of.
They don't,
they don't have to accommodate the,
the advertising units that we do.
So,
um,
so part of that is jealousy.
Um,
I also think over it and why mag.com New
York magazine's site,
I think,
um,
Ian Adelman,
uh,
the design director there is doing a
really terrific job,
um,
uh,
making,
um,
a site that's not that different from
ours,
but is I think infused,
um,
a lot more,
I think,
um,
uh,
sort of playfulness then the times is,
and,
um,
has just done a terrific job over the
past few years.
Um,
uh,
creating,
a site that's really full of character
and I think really,
really accurately translates the,
the personality of the print magazine to
the web without being slavish to the
print side.
Yeah.